تلاشت ذكرياتها لكن اثارها ما تزال مستمره
حرب العراق حطمت ثقه الشعب البريطاني
بحكومته رغم مرور 20 عاما تقول صحيفه
الجارديان البريطانيه المملكه المتحده
اليوم تعاني اكثر من اي وقت مضى من السخط
الشعبي والقلق بسبب عدم ثقه البريطانيين
بحكومتهم بعدما شاركت الولايات المتحده
بقرار الحرب على العراق الذكرى العشرون
تذكر باكبر كارثه سياسيه وانسانيه تورطت
فيها المملكه المتحده منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه والسبب كان رئيس الحكومه
البريطانيه السابق توني بلير وذكرى تذكر
ايضا باللحظه التي بدا فيها مركز الثقل
السياسي المفترض في بريطانيا يترنح على
نحو متهور وكارثي بحسب الصحيفه البريطانيه
التي اعادت التذكير بان حزب المحافظين
والغالبيه العظمى من الصحافه البريطانيه
دعموا حرب العراق حين ها وعليه تشدد
الجارديان بان الذكرى السنويه لتلك الحرب
المدمره تعد مثالا حيا على مخاطر التفكير
على نحو جماعي والنتائج القاتمه التي يفضي
اليها اختزال الحقائق المعقده في روايات
بسيطه قبل ان نكمل دعونا نشاهد بعض هذه
المشاهد من تلك الحرب ونعود
وتضيف الجارديان بان العود او انه بالعوده
سريعا الى تقارير الصادره خلال الحرب تجعل
المرء يدرك الفجوه العميقه التي شكلتها
تلك الاحداث بين السلطه وسياساتها من جهه
وجمهور الشعب البريطاني من جهه اخرى
تداعيات لم تنتهي هنا فقرار المشاركه في
الحرب ضد العراق للتخصص جل رئيس الوزراء
السابق توني بلير السياسيه لبال وقضى على
رؤيه حزب العمال التي كانت تقدم بريطانيا
بصفاتها دوله فتيه واثقه من نفسها اما
الشعب العراقي الذي يعاني جروحا كبيره
ويعيش ازمات متلاحقه وفي المنطقه ككل ما
زالوا يعانون يوميا بسبب تداعيات تلك
الحرب فيما لا تزال التركيبه السياسيه
الشيعيه محافظه على مكانتها باعتبارها
المستفيد الاول من سقوط نظام الرئيس
السابق صدام حسين وفق مراقبين للتطورات
الحاصله